it's on because I think a lot of people
here could make a lot more money if they
eliminated two things one laziness to be
very frank and and too idealistic points
of view of how they've made their money
in the past I think one of the biggest
concerns I have sitting here in a world
where I'm hungry to get one to two
people three people to get a lot of
value out of this talk is the way you
made your money before is my enemy the
way you've been successful yesterday is
my enemy
it is stunning if you understood what
runs through my head every morning on
how little I think anybody should give a
[ __ ] about anything I achieved yesterday
back you're really only as good as your
last at-bat and let me give you a direct
tactic that I think a lot of you guys
can use a couple books ago because I
decided to write those kind of things I
wrote a book called the Thank You
economy super interesting to me it's the
notion of if you provide so much upfront
value to an individual can you actually
guilt them into buying [ __ ] especially
if all your actions are predicated on
not expecting them to buy it that's the
big part when the energy of your tactics
is to convert you will lose when your
energy is to disproportionately bring
value and let the chips fall where they
may
you will win
you